- For most of my life, I was told that
I was never going to be
able to throw a curveball,
let alone pitch, because of my condition.
Looking back on it, I just
want to prove people wrong.
I just go out there, I grab the ball,
and I think to myself, "I run this game."
Growing up, my mom, my dad, they wanted
me and my brother to play sports,
find something that we love.
I got a lot of stares
and a lot of questions
but for me, I’m always just like,
"Yeah, I was born with it."
It's like I don't know
any other way, this is me.
- Dylan has Proteus syndrome.
Once a baby is born, their
body parts never stop growing.
In the first five years of his life,
he had six surgeries,
but Dylan's been able
to deal with those and adapt.
- In my case, it was my
fingers and my toes.
I can't really move these three fingers
and then these two.
I had issues that most
people take for granted,
like buttoning up a shirt.
And the sleeved ones, those are the worst.
- He thinks that if you can do it,
he should be able to do it, and
he figures out how to do it.
- [Dylan] Baseball has
always been my favorite sport
but I've had some obstacles 'cause
I've had to figure out how to catch,
'cause I can't squeeze my glove,
and it's the same thing
with my curveball.
Most people have both fingers on it but
I just use one, and I learned a new grip.
- The way the ball comes
off of his middle finger
and ring finger, he just
gets a lot more spin
than normal people do.
- It turns out, because of my condition,
I can throw a curve ball
that few other pitchers can.
Even though I wasn't the fastest pitcher
and I didn't have the
greatest body for pitching,
I always knew that I could pitch because
I was accurate and I could hit my spots.
- When Dylan came here as a freshman,
he was never a guy that
we thought was gonna
contribute as much as he did.
And almost by accident
he got his opportunity.
- [Dylan] We were playing our rival school
in the second game of the year,
and our pitcher was struggling.
- [Joe] Dylan was the
only pitcher on the bench
and he threw three scoreless innings.
Then we kind of knew at that
point that we had something.
- After that my ERA was the
second best on the team.
The highlight of the year for me was
when I came two outs shy
of throwing a no-hitter.
A lot of people were surprised, but
I knew that I could do it and it just
showed everyone that I'm a good pitcher.
My family who's always loving and said,
"Just be you, everything will work out."